hi everyone
my name is matt graham
uh i'm here to talk about a hot new
topic on the internet
bytecode assembly languages who doesn't
know a 15 year old who's interested in
that
professionally as you said i'm a
software engineer at etsy
uh just to clarify this is a personal
project not an etsy project
just want to preempt anyone tweeting
etsy's ditching php
so don't get me in trouble uh
it's still experimental um but i hope
you'll find some notable things about it
nonetheless
so again a kubert is by code assembly
language and virtual machine
and the reason i wanted to write it is
to make
writing other programming programming
languages easier
to make it so to take the the difficult
parts of implementing the execution of a
programming language
and push them down into the virtual
machine so the client languages don't
need to implement those features
themselves
and also i'm trying to take you know a
bunch of
disparate features that i found useful
in other programming language
environments
and recombine them into a single virtual
machine
qubert and the the last thing then is
novels there's some novel error handling
that i'll get into later so when i get
to that section
look out for that
all right so it may not surprise you i
didn't set out to to write
a bytecode assembly language um
i take this as a positive sign because
so many successful software projects
usually have something accidental in
them
at some point so starting off with that
uh and let me go back a minute to just
explain how how this happened
so this is what computers looked like
when i started with them
and they were they were slow megahertz
and then we started making them faster
largely by making them faster
so you know they were going to keep
getting faster right that was the
expectation
obviously that didn't happen um
the hardware engineers were like no it's
too hard
so they they found a way to weasel out
of making them faster
and that is just to say we're gonna make
more of them
so what that let them do is say hey look
chips are better they're now you now
have two cores instead of one
uh and if that's a problem it's a
software problem so
good luck guys so suddenly we have
concurrency
um the problem with that is here's a
quote from joe armstrong
uh programming languages reflect the
hardware they were designed for
uh i think i actually misquoted that i
forgot to write it down
exactly right ask me for the for the
exact quote later
uh it was something like that though
uh and so the problem with that is most
of the programming languages that we use
today were designed and implemented in
the context of
software getting faster by chips having
higher clock speeds
which is no longer the case chips have
more
more cores and that are not necessarily
faster
so what that means is it's great for us
it's time for us to you know do have
some interesting problems
taking old programming languages and
retrofitting them to concurrency
designing new ones that are built from
the beginning to have better support for
concurrency
uh so everyone's having fun uh who's in
this industry except for one person
uh joe joe armstrong is the creator of
erlang he's like
what took you all so long
uh so these issues with concurrency uh
led me to want to
build a functional programming language
a new a new language that
handled concurrency better handled the
uh
the error handling better like i was
talking about and that programming
language is called jazz
but i'm not going to talk about that
because uh
well that's uh that's an example that
i'll use for the client language but
what happened is i started working on
the virtual machine for for jazz
and i'm working on the virtual machine
trying to get it to execute i'm thinking
this would be a lot easier to test
and debug and just understand and make
it work better if
if it had its own assembly language so
i started working on that then and that
also has an interesting
property where it allows the virtual
machine to have an interface
that any any language can target
any other client language can target and
then be interoperable between them
uh so now is developing two programming
languages
okay so hubert what's it about um first
well where does it fit um kubert
uh any programming language would
compile to kubert assembly language
and then the computer kubert assemble
compiler will compile that to the
bytecode
and the virtual machine will execute
that and run it and interact with the
operating system and something
this is basically the same place in the
stack that the jvm fits
right so the goal then is to also
provide interoperability and let any
programming language that
that someone might write to target
kubert interact and be callable from
others
so what are the applications that i'm
looking for here
i'm a server side developer web
developer etsy's a website
that kind of thing so those are the
problems that i'm most looking to solve
but also it should be just generic right
it should be
usable as any kind of uh language
virtual machine
and one of the other things that dsl is
everyone you know we always talk about
dsls but
they're not used that often and one of
the reasons they're not used is
it's difficult to go from a dsl to code
execution
and so the hope here is that by making
it easy to
sort of support all the code execution
and target the code execution
you can implement a lot less in the dsl
part of the
the system uh and one actually common
dsl that we use is template languages
a lot of these languages compile to java
or php or some other language or
interpreted at runtime by ruby or python
but we can also just take those
languages and compile them straight
to the byte code of the virtual machine
all right and it should be embeddable as
a concurrency
library also to provide uh concurrency
to
other languages that don't necessarily
have it but want to be able to have
access to
currency or asynchronous io and the
other features
available so these applications led me
to these priorities
um number one has to have good
concurrency
it's not going to have good concurrency
we've already got java and c
plus so that is covered um
and it's got to be interoperable and
there's a lot of people running web
servers
in the cloud now and those web servers
have low resources so
can't be too memory intensive and needs
to be built with that in mind
so down at the bottom here is straight
line performance
that's less of a uh priority i'm sort of
aiming to follow the
the path laid out by java and erlang and
the
hip-hop vm starting off as
an an interpreted implementation and
then you know bringing in jet
compilation and performance enhancements
later
all right so the language priorities
it's an assembly language
but it's still got to be accessible and
the whole point is to be easy to use for
language developers so accessibility is
number one priority in the language
easy easy to use
and it's got to be writable by the
computer which
may lead to it being a little more
verbose than a language that's meant to
be writable by a human
oops and readable by the language
designer whoever's building the the
client language
needs to be able to look at the kubert
code that they've generated and be able
to read it sufficiently to say
yes that's what i wanted to do or no
that's not what i wanted to do
and finally debuggable in the client
language
an example is like coffeescript compiles
to javascript which then runs
in the browser or something but when
you're going to debug that
you're debugging javascript which is
kind of a problematic interface so
uh keyword definitely needs to be um
debuggable
in whatever client language it was
implemented with
which also then leads to really being
readable or writable by the client
language developer
uh the client language user anyway um
not being much of a priority hopefully
they don't need to know that kubert
is there or the any of the assembly
language just like a python developer a
c developer doesn't
know have to worry about the assembly
language that their code generates
usually okay so there are some
precedents
parrot is an example that tried to do
this
tried try is trying i don't know if
anyone is particular about that
has has not succeeded yet at least that
is the
the virtual machine for pearl it's also
was they were hoping to target python
and maybe php that hasn't really worked
out
um the jvm is obviously supremely
successful
uh tons of languages are supporting that
and it's in the similar similar space
and then finally uh the language elixir
has demonstrated that erlang
can successfully host languages as well
so this is a big challenge to improve on
these options um but
i think there's there's still room for
for one more language
otherwise why would we all be here
all right so some quick basics about uh
kubert
it is uh register based similar to lua
erlang
some others it supports runtime
polymorphism
static type information uh inline
asynchronous i o so that means
asynchronous io without callbacks uh so
you just have to say read write read
write
and the virtual machine handles the
scheduling so you don't have to
build generate uh callbacks or even
worse have users write callbacks
and it also supports pattern matching
because that's that's great anyone
pattern matching is great i just want to
plug pattern matching real quick
all right all right so here's some code
uh
and features it's a programming language
so i definitely want to show code
uh it's an assembly language so i'm
going to try to keep it to a minimum
all right gotta see hello world um
of course for any programming language
the this is
pretty simple uh the first line
declares the main function that returns
void
the second line loads the the print
function
into a register and the third line loads
the hello world constant into the first
parameter of the
print function and then the fourth line
calls it so that's it's pretty simple
obviously it's it's more than most
languages but again it's an assembly
language so
that's verbosity will come with that a
little bit
uh here's hello world in swedish
that's one of the nice things about a
virtual machine is it handles stuff like
utf-8 for you
obviously not unique to kubert all right
so i've talked a lot about concurrency
there are two two models for concurrency
in qbert
process whoa processes and forks
get into those in a bit first i already
spilled the beans on this
workers workers are sort of more of a
system cubert system level thing they're
not really
code related uh it's just one cpu to a
worker and the worker handles the
scheduling and
stuff like that so then within
uh worker zoom into that each worker has
multiple processes
uh probably more than three but
that's all that fit on the slide
and a process is similar to an erlang
process it's
if you're familiar with erlang it's very
similar to that it's a new new call
stack so it's not related to
the calling or the creating process at
all
and processes interact with each other
via message passing
and this is what you would use to
implement the actor model for example
okay so here's just a quick sequence
diagram there's a main process it calls
new proc creates an active process
and then calls the send function the
actor receives the message
does some processing and sends it back
very simple
very similar to other models
so here's the code qr code to do that
load the some actor function and just
call new proc
on it and it stores the the pit of the
new process id of the new
process in the first parameter there so
not bad for an assembly language i think
and then a few more lines will actually
send the message
to it so you just load the core the send
function
pass in the the process id as the first
parameter and the
whatever message you want to pass as the
second parameter and call it so
pretty quick six lines and this is
hopefully makes it
is is easy and stuff that's easy for
client languages to implement this kind
of thing
so the other model is fork uh
so each each process in a
in a worker each process will have a
call stack or
kubert's version as a call tree and it's
a call tree because
each function can fork within the
context of that function
so if a fork then is a section of
the function that runs in parallel or
asynchronously to the rest of the
function
um it's they're all self-contained
within the function so if
forks are still running the main fork
won't return until the others are
finished
and forks communicate via promises
rather than via messages
and then there's a weight instruction
also to to wait on the
process or to wait on a promise from
another fork
so here's another diagram for that you
can see there's
the the main fork there is going along
and it says fork and promise x
and then fork again and promise y uh
and then it goes ahead and says query
the db and assign the result to that
in z meanwhile over here it's querying
the database
uh on those two forks and then
um over back on the first fork it's
saying you know what wait for x
and i'm not gonna do i'm just going to
wait for those other forks to finish
so once these finish they get the data
from the database assign it to
y and then so they've sort of finished
the promise and then they're like all
right i'm done i'm out
and they just disappear go away
uh and then uh on the main fork it gets
x
it gets y and does some processing with
those or returns them or whatever it
wants to do
okay so here's some quick code to do
that
fork and it says okay put a promise and
name that
this fork block will eventually set
and so it says loads of function called
query name database
calls it and then assigns the result to
the to the name
variable and so that's done
meanwhile while that's happening on the
bottom here it the main fork just
continues and says all right go query
the address database
and store that in the address variable
and then when you're done with that go
ahead and wait on the name
and so whenever these actually deliver
get
processed it's not necessarily they'll
go in
asynchronously or in parallel it's not
the developers
they can just say you know fork go do
this fork go do that and i'll
i'll hear about it when when you come
back
um so those are the two the two models
for cubic
concurrency saying that too many times
uh and now here is the failure stuff
that i was talking about earlier
this to me is the the most interesting
part um
so i would definitely uh
i definitely like this because i'm a big
fan of failures for me that's
kind of the fun part of software
development right um
we only work on it if it's broken uh and
if it's not breaking how interesting can
it be right
it works uh okay so there's been a long
debate about
exceptions or or error values uh
exceptions were winning for a while
and now go and erlang are coming in and
they're like no no their values
uh so that's making a comeback hubert
has an interesting answer to this
but let's quickly go through here
uh so what are the problems with
exceptions
one they're wordy there's a three to two
boilerplate to code ratio here
uh that's not very good uh and second um
what's interesting here about exceptions
is it takes the results of foo foo
executes and takes the result
and it puts it in a unless foo failed
and then it puts it in e
and the same thing with bar if bar
succeeds it puts the result
in b or if it fails it puts the result
in e
so it's just an interesting idea to say
like we're taking one function we're
calling it
and then kind of just sending the result
in different directions
um and the other thing here is that you
know with foo
and bar like if you once you get into
the exception handler
and you're like okay i failed well what
failed uh foo or bar
uh you don't know right so you've looked
in the logs and found the stack trace
but the code it's a lot harder to tell
so if you want to know you can do this
but now you've got suddenly a lot more
boilerplate going on
and it still fits on the screen at least
so error values right error values are
good this is the
standard c1 the negative integer um
that's great it doesn't tell you a lot
and it tells you even less if you don't
check it right
so there's a problem um
haskell is nothing at least you have to
check it right because otherwise you
can't get it but
after that it's like you failed sorry um
so you're guessing what what failed why
it failed
haskell also has the either type which
is a little better because you can at
least pass
information about the failure and get
some sense of why it failed
uh maybe try to recover from it um but
then things start to get hairy right
because you got two types in the either
uh there's like either a b or whatever
whatever you call it
uh and then you start adding monads and
the type suddenly the type
declaration gets really long um
so that's not so great and then erlang
and grow take the error and they wrap it
inside a
little failure envelope um and
it says error and then the information
about the error or okay or success or
something
and then information about that which is
good you know you get you get
information there
but all these have the same problem and
that is that the the error information
corrupts
the type of the function it takes a
function that
you just want to return a string and
suddenly you now have to return the
string
plus all this other information about
about the error
which makes chaining function calls
difficult
you can't just say you know call foo and
pass it to bar
because you have to unpack it and see
what what fail to get the result out of
it
all right so what does kubert do hubert
tries to
combine these and take take the good
from both
so kubert is has static type information
so every function returns the type
that it uh declares a type that it
returns
in this example do something returns an
integer um
but at least for me software is not math
on a chalkboard i know some languages
disagree
uh but when we're running code in
production like those are real live
electrons
um and they are crazy uh
and so funny stuff happens from any
function definitely places where you
wouldn't expect it
uh so keyword says all right you know
forget that everything can fail
there is no there is no concept of
something that cannot fail
so kubrick makes failure an implicit
possible result
of every operation this so this function
returns an integer
or returns a failure every function in
qubit returns an integer or a failure
and the failure is implicit so you don't
have to declare it as part of the return
type
and then the calling code can look at
that and say all right let me check for
the
failure uh there's a if fail instruction
if not fail instruction
to say um yeah that's good or no it's
not
or you can just not check it and this is
this is interesting because now kubert
will check it for you
so you just go ahead and say in this
example you say all right here's
uh put 7 into x and put a
y is a failure i don't know how it got
there we tried to divide by 0 earlier
and then we want to add seven to the
failure
kubert the virtual machine is going to
look at that and say
hold on slow down you can't do that uh
you're
you better stop so it takes that failure
and passes it up the call stack to the
caller
and then the caller can do the same
thing it can check the error or it
cannot
and what this does is uh you know by the
virtual machine giving special
treatment to failures the language lets
the developer focus on the program logic
and worry uh but still get the error
checking
even if they're not necessarily checking
it themselves
all right and so what that does is it
gives us an interesting stack trace
here's a
similar stack trace to the from
something like that code
that i just showed uh come into main and
main calls up to foo
these arrows on the left here are saying
in or out right so the error pointing
right means a call in to that function
so call in tofu a call into bar and then
they're on line 14
bar freaked out and it's like ah divide
by zero um
so that returns back down to foo it
returns an error and foo keeps going
it's like
i don't have time for errors i'm going
to keep going let me try to do something
here on line 22.
and the vm is like no no no you can't do
that so it says all right we're going to
take this error we're going to send it
back down to main
main you know it's hello world so they
forgot to check errors
and try to use it on line 35 and the
virtual machine is like all right you're
done
we're exiting we're printing the stack
trace and this is what it looks so you
get the trace
going in up the stack deeper into the
stack
and then also on the way back down as
you use the functions
uh and as you try to use the variables
that failed
so that's uh that's the interesting
answer there
um about failure handling
and let's see so it's five after
i have multiple dispatch or i can skip
it it's kind of it's
kind of hairy i'll just i'll go fast um
let's see all right so close uh i
mentioned earlier
uh that kubert has support for multiple
dispatch
it's really more like multi-parameter
type classes
and that is like if you pass x a string
and an int
to an integer it should have different
polymorphic behavior than if you pass
an intense string so
kubrick uses protocols it's based on
similar to closure protocol or haskell
class
it's a type class basically and then
there's a binding which is similar to
the
haskell instance or clojurify
um roughly the same analogous base um
here's what it would look like an
example protocol declares the type
parameters uh and a function that
returns a
void and takes two parameters uh and
here's how a binding is declared i'm
skipping past this it's okay
if it's like this looks crazy um
and then this is an implementation for
uh the protocol for a string and an int
and here's what the code does it down
down there it just says print string and
int
and then here's the opposite
implementation that says does the same
thing for an int and a string in reverse
order
and some test code to call it passes an
intent a string and calls the function
and then a string in it and calls the
function
and then the output here is foo in
string foo string int
so this is just sort of a standard
walkthrough of how
how it handles multiple dispatch again
multiple type
type classes uh stefan karpinski is
going to be doing a talk about multiple
dispatch in julia and how they use that
in the core julie libraries tomorrow
afternoon
so if this looks good you should check
that out
all right so just about done so what's
what's next for
kubert um a language can only be as
successful
as it can only be successful if people
you people are using it to
write code um and write programs with it
or in this case
write programs that write programs with
it
um so you know esperanto for example
not a successful language
all right uh so if anyone's out there
who finds this
you know hopefully someone found this
interesting related to something you're
working on thinking about
uh just want to experiment with it um
definitely let me know
um even if you just want to tell me you
think you know this project is crazy
or i'm going about it all wrong it's
fine too uh so i'm here to meet you hear
what people are
thinking about stuff like this and think
about related uh what you have
for related stuff so definitely i'd like
to talk to you um
i didn't want to risk a live demo in the
talk so but i'm happy to provide one
later on uh if you're interested in that
uh and that's all that i've got so thank
you very much
and are there any questions oh yes
please
thank you